with the coming of spring the fields of
ukraine have turned bright green
wheat and other grains sprouting as far
as the eye can see
[Music]
but even farming is risky in a country
at war
workers now wear a safety vest
because of the shelling especially at
dawn says petro beswarchni
he usually produces about 10 000 tons of
various types of grain per year by 2022
is full of anguish
most of our farming land is in the
kursan region now under russian
occupation they stole what we'd stocked
in our warehouses and in grain elevators
and we will lose the autumn and spring
crops there is a drone video that shows
my warehouses burning we have massive
losses some colleagues still there tell
me that the russians want to confiscate
land and create collective farms like
during soviet times
before the war
ukraine produced about a hundred million
tons of wheat corn rapeseed and barley
per year it was also a top producer of
sunflower oil
only 20 percent was for domestic
consumption the rest made its way to
markets in china india the middle east
and africa
but since russia's invasion exports have
nearly stopped
ukraine now is looking into other
options to export the grain one of them
would be to transport it by train to a
neighboring country the problem is the
railway system needs to be adapted
the soviet-built tracks are wider than
european ones so stocks need to be
offloaded and reloaded before continuing
their journey
about 25 million tons are wasting in
silos around the country
since russia imposed a blockade on the
black sea ports like odessa since
operations have come to a grinding halt
other maritime routes through romania or
bulgaria are being considered
ukraine
ukraine exports 10 to 14 percent of
world demand we are number one in
sunflower oil now we have excess of oil
and sunflowers world prices are at a
historical high
if the export question isn't sold soon
the prices will continue to increase
finding ways to rein in global prices is
a priority at the g7 summit but with the
war raging in the east and south of the
country where the main agricultural
regions are located
production is likely to decrease by as
much as 35 percent
making it one of the most urgent
humanitarian crisis to be solved to
avoid shortages in global food supplies
al jazeera odessa